[Musique]
salut à tous aujourd'hui une vidéo un
petit peu rapide et un petit peu courte
pour vous parler d'une nouvelle qui est
tombée il ya deux jours me semble-t-il
au sujet de apple a priori apple serait
en train de bosser du mois aurait bossé
et s'apprêterait à sortir d'ici très peu
de temps un nouvel ipad probablement en
ehpad pro un ipad qui ferait que je te
dise pas de bêtises 10,5 pousse alors
c'est une info qui nous vient du site
qui s'appelle qui s'appelle qui
s'appelle un time to find mac qui a
révélé l'info vient par contre ça vient
d'une capture d'écran d'un des
fournisseurs de la coque arrière qui
aurait laissé traîner malencontreusement
à rétro que l'animé ce qu'elle
effectivement on voit apparaître très
bien là le produit qui est sorti en
février à savoir la protection arrière
pour l'ipad pro 12.9 hélas ici on voit
apparaître une protection arrière pour
un ipad 10.5 qui devrait sortir en juin
2017 alors peut-être qu'on n'aille pas
de trop toujours utile qui aurait
effectivement à priori un nouvel ipad
qui devrait sortir en juin de cette
année j'ai d'ailleurs le marché en règle
générale au niveau du business des
tablettes
c'est un marché qui après avoir
fonctionné se casse la gueule depuis
maintenant un petit peu plus d'un an
la raison est super simple c'est que
l'on voit très bien qui à microsoft qui
a fait une vraie offensive avec ça
son ordinateur 2 ans dans tablettes et
ordi avec la surface et ça c'est quelque
chose qui est effectivement beaucoup nui
au business des tablettes mais du coup
il ya une vraie chute en termes de
ventes chez apple ça a été calme et
assez significatif un petit peu moins
chez samsung alors apple avec son ipad
reste quand même leader dans le marché
par contre le marché en lui-même se
casse la gueule
le but avec ce nouvel ipad qu'on
retrouverait normalement studio n'avait
pas de crocs en 10.15 serait
effectivement de concurrencer
directement ce marché des ordis 2 en
tablette ordi comme peut proposer
microsoft d'avoir une tablette avec un
clavier et un stylet ce qui permet
effectivement de se placer sur un marché
qui fonctionne très bien qui plaît
énormément qui évite d'avoir un ordi qui
est vie d'abord l'ordi et la tablette
est en même temps et d'avoir un peu le 2
ans alors ce produit devrait a priori
être annoncée au mois de juin lors de la
keynote de la wwdc qui est là qui note
des développeurs
de développer dédiées exclusivement
dédié aux développeurs
donc ce produit devrait être annoncée à
cette occasion normalement il n'y a rien
qui a annoncé en terme de hardware à ce
moment là on est plus sûr du software
ont le temps d avance au niveau de laïos
pour activement pour l'ipad pour
l'iphone pour la watch mais apple
pourrait très bien effectivement faire
une annonce pour annoncer ce nouveau
ipad
donc on va veiller effectivement magasin
très très près parce que ça sera le 5
juin prochain
alors il ya eu un ipad jacques était
dévoilée au mois de mars dernier c'est
l'ipad
9.7 pouces à 409 euros
l'idée effectivement c'est d'avoir un
ipad d'entrée de gamme je dirais
beaucoup moins cher alors d'entrée de
gamme beaucoup moins cher en nature des
guillemets chez apple parce que 409
euros
ça fait quand même une somme coquette
mais ça permet effectivement d'avoir ce
produit d'appel
chez apple qui est quand même bien
positionnés en termes de taille d'autant
plus qu'on sait que microsoft va
annoncer la surface pro 4 le 23 mai
prochain donc vraiment dans les jours à
venir
donc apple se doit de réagir pour garder
je dirais une position et et garder une
place sur le marché de la tablette ce
qui ne vas plus réellement être des
tablettes va vraiment contrôler la table
at-elle baissé entre eux deux en or et
c'est dans ce sens là a priori qu'il
devrait aller dans cette direction pour
garder une dynamique pour rebooster les
ventes et pour faire que l'ipad continue
quand même à avoir de belles heures et
de beaux jours devant lui alors pour
l'instant la seule info qu'on a c'est
celle ci c'est effectivement ce rétro
planning qui te dit qu' a priori cet
ipad 10 points 5 pouces qui va sortir en
juin 2017 on a absolument aucune idée en
termes de tarifs absolument aucune idée
en termes de date de livraison de choses
comme ça
a priori joint donc elle sera annoncée
en juin elle devra être commercialisé
très peu de temps après mais voilà pas
plus d'infos pour l'instant savoir
comment ils vont se positionner par
rapport à microsoft par rapport à cette
surface pro 4
toujours est il que kim on voit qu'il ya
une vraie réaction d'apple pour pouvoir
se positionner sur ce marché et ne pas
trop perdre de business donc dis moi ce
que t'en penses toi est ce que tu penses
que c'est une bonne idée que l'ipad
aille vers effectivement une
démocratisation de l'ipad pro crêtes en
avait pas de progrès en public avec ce
clavier est ce stylet mais moi tout en
commentaire est-ce que tu as un ipad
déjà est ce que tu avais pas d'un ipad
est ce que tu l'utilisent beaucoup parce
que moi c'était la question que nous
supposée à l'époque où l'ipad est sorti
tu dis que tu as un ordi tu as un ipad
tara d'iphone alors tout est dans le
même écosystème mais il ya quand même
beaucoup de doublons donc si tu es un
ipad est ce qu'il a pour toi une force
one était particulière est ce que tu
passe moins de temps sur ton portable
est-ce que tu passe moins de temps sur
ton téléphone mais moi tous ces
commentaires je te remercie d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo je reviens très
bientôt pour des vidéos un petit peu
plus complète un petit peu plus
construite autour autour du bloc ce que
j'aime beaucoup faire je te remercie
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo je
t'embrasse je te souhaite beaucoup de
bonheur beaucoup de joie mu toi bien &
abonne toi à la chaîne allez ciao à plus
tard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]